wer würde er kalte Füße vor der Hochzeit
bekommen wer würde er Kinder wollen wer
würde er einer Sekte beitreten wer würde
er in der
Öffentlichkeit cheers prüßchen gr
[Musik]
un Franken kostet der Glühwein in
unserem Hotel ist halt echt lauwarmm die
den da kurz mit dieser Kaffeemaschine so
aufgeheizt und so einem Kelch komplett
einmal durchgeschäumt okay Fang wir an
oh schmeckt aber
Alkohol ja wir fangen an also wir haben
heute nicht wirklich was zu tun denn es
ist der letzte Tag hier und wir haben
unsere skisen abgegeben und deswegen
drehen wir heute ein wer würde
er so lustig couple
Challenge freust du dich bin excited wer
würde er bei Seven Verss white mitmachen
1 2 3 kann ich jetzt aufmachen ja ja ja
ja ja ja ja easy du hast auch schon
mehrmals gesagt dass du litally nicht
einen Tag überleben würdest
deswegen bin ich jetzt davon ausgegangen
das hat sich nicht geändert deine
Meinung dazu ja aber ich denke auch weil
du so gut rennst also du rennst ja
wirklich viel und schnell könntest du
halt viel mehr Meter machen um Sachen zu
suchen aber d Verbrauch ich auch viel
mehr Energie und du hast Skifahren
gelernt das stimmt die wel steht dir
offen wer Skifahren kann kann auch be
überleben wer würde er einen Löffel
Butter essen 1 2
3 ich bin ich würde direkt kotzen ich
bin timo ist so ein picky Eater also
nicht nicht ganz so schlimm wie früher
habe ich das Gefühl du traust dich schon
mittlerweile mehr aber sobald es an
Konsistenz und sowas geht bist du so
schnell immer raus jo okay das stimmt
aber ich meine Leute was ein Kilo Butter
oder was löffelbutter Löffel löel
löffelbutter ne ich würde ja auch ein
Löffel Öl nehme ich auch manchmal
einfach nur es gesund ist ja nee das ist
nicht mein Jam
irgendwie ist voll süß ja der ist so süß
weil er nicht so heiß ist müssen den
schnell trinken ne Franken dafür für ein
halbwarmen insane oder ja wer würde er
einfach mal aus Spaß aus dem Fenster
springen um zu testen ob es weh tut 3 2
1 das klingt voll wie was machst du tut
eentlich ich WTE ein mal
ausprobieren wer würde er von einer zu
springen oh
okay 3
Z die Augen zu okay an die Regeln sorry
wer würde eher einer Sekte
beitreten 3 2
1 du 100% ich müsste nur einer davon
überzeugen was für benefits das hat und
du wärst so voll drin das gleich hätte
ich bei dir gezogen du bist immer so
schnell von irgend Sachen begeistert wo
ich sage e Vanessa chill mal ja das scam
ja nein aber das ist
voll aber ich habe das Gefühl ich bin
auch ein bisschen zu verkopft um da mich
reinlegen zu lassen sobald es immer so
scamy W B auch so alles was so ich bin
auch nicht so der religiöse Typ alles
was irgendwie so die Richtung Sekte ja
die meisten Leute wissen ja nicht dass
sie in eine Sekte kommen wenn sie dann
in die Sekte gehen ja aber so
gemeinschaftskonstrukte die sich
irgendwie sehr darauf beruhen irgendwie
auf die Gemeinschaft alles was so dann
Kriterien hat und so da ist
kein Bo ne bin ich ne bin ich nicht so
angreifbar für einzäer dem B schon eher
einzgänger ich glaub keiner von uns
beiden ich wer zu verkopft um das alles
gleich zu durchschauen und du hast
einfach keinen Bock auf
Gruppe Leute ich bleib alleine Ciao uh
auch spannend wer würde er auswandern uh
dre 2
1 ich glaub schon ich habe schon auch
voll Bock aber du liebst ich liebe
Berlin ich lieb irgendwie Familie
Familien ne ist mir schon auch wichtig
auch wenn ich jetzt meine Familie jetzt
ir 6 Stunden entfernt wohn aber halt so
komplettes Ausland ist halt schon krass
abkappen von allem so und du bist ja
schon eher ne ja ich habe aber bei mir
ist auch so wie ein bisschen wie
Krankheit jedes Mal wenn wir einem neuen
Ort sind will ich da mal gleich
hinziehen und bin so hier könnten wir
eigentlich auch Leben so bei mir ist so
das eine Extrem also aber ich liebe
Berlin auch ich find es auch schön und
jetzt mit unserer neuen Wohnung ich
glaube das wird richtig cool ja ich
glaube darauf freue ich mich am meisten
dass wir halt auch mal so ein bisschen
so ein Space haben den wir bisschen
selber gestalten können denn nicht weil
so viele Berliner Mietwohnungen sehen
und fühlen sich halt an wie Berliner
Mietwohnungen und die sind völlig fein
wenn sie aber jetzt nicht so teuer
wärden also früher hatte ich das Gefühl
hat man das viel mehr also einfach
hingenommen gesagt ja klar wohne ich
hier das ist zwar nicht alles wie ich es
mir wünsche aber das ist halt okay aber
ich habe das Gefühl mittlerweile weil
die Mieten so teuer werden ist es halt
zu vergleichen mit kaufen und dann denk
mal so ja 100% wer würde eher eine Woche
nicht Duschen 3 2
1 ich bin die dreckige von uns
beiden ja du bist halt aber timo ist
auch von aus einem Haushalt gekommen wo
die Eltern jeden Morgen Duschen jeden
Morgen werden sich die Haare gewaschen
und da wir sich was ja auch nicht so
gesund ist ne jeed jeden Tag Haare
waschen soll ja ist auch nicht so gut
nee ist wirklich nicht so gut und ich
komme aus einem Haushalt da ich glaub
meine Eltern haben mich in meiner
Kindheit nicht einmal gefragt ob ich
geduscht habe auch krass das war völlig
kein Thema okay wer würde er kriminell
werden okay 3 2
1 ja ja ich habe auf uns beide gezeigt
weil ich würde kriminell werden einfach
weil ich aus der Hut komme ich find du
hast eigentlich gar keine kriminelle
Energie schonimmer so dass du auch alles
s nach den Regeln laufen du bist W gegen
Regeln verstoßt bist du richtig
angepisst und bist so das geht nicht das
können wir nicht machen ja doch doch
doch stimm du kminell wer ich gar nicht
bei mir komm juckt nicht komm ich dachte
auch irgendwie passt schon mäßig so ja
timo ist so ein bisschen also der der
lügt doch ganz gerne würdest eher
Polizistin werden ich würde dich eher
jagen Recht und Ordnung sen wer würde er
eine Rolex kaufen
Rolex Rolex 3 2
1 ja obwohl du eher wenn es darum geht
wirklich Geld damit zu machenens so als
Geldanlage O ist so ein bisschen into
Aktien und sowas damit beschäftigt er
sich schon ich gar nicht ich würde halt
nur aus dem Prestige kaufen um eine
Rolex zu haben ich bin halt gar nicht so
der Typ der irgendwie so Uhren Autos so
materielle Gegenstände wo ich kein kein
nutzen so richtig draus hab das juckt
mich gar nicht eben aber wenn jetzt
jemand erzählen würde wie sich das lohnt
eine zu kaufen und dann irgendwann ein
paar Jahren zu verkaufen weil sie halt
eine wertsteigung hat oder halt das
würdest Du dann schon ich würd es nur
kaufen um zu tragen for the flags aber
auch nur im
Zimmer nur hier wür ich sagen
Leute würde er beim Spieleabend sauer
werden und das Brett umschmeißen 3 2
1 ja wahinlich schon obwohl du aber auch
so ein emotionaler Typ bist ich hab auch
ich habe auch gerade gehadert ich bin
eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen ja
manchmal triggert du bei sowas aber du
bist ja ich weiß es nicht aber keiner
von uns beiden würde das je eigentlich
machen eher ich aber auch nur wenn ich
was getrunken hätte und richtig richtig
böse oder so wä so richtig so wenn BSI
rauskommen würde ja weil manchmal trinkt
man Alkohol also jetzt ne Alkohol Maßen
genießen und sowas aber manchmal habe
ich dann schon Stimmungsschwankung das
immer so das Zeichen so uh heute ist
kein guter Tag ZOH trinken das ist immer
das Problem mit Alkohol das versteckt
finde ich immer deine Stimmung wenn du
halt schon eh schlecht drauf bist oder
wütend oder so und du dann noch Alkohol
trinkst dann pusht du deine negativen
Emotionen andersrum ist es halt wenn du
mega gut drauf bist und Alkohol trinkst
dann hast du das Gefühl du bist immer
glücklicher ja und Unterschied es gibt
auch irgendwie Unterschied beim Alkohol
Sorten ir ich hab Gefühl manchmal macht
Wein so richtig crazy drunk hier
manchmal so gechillt dann gib wieder so
Sorten die machen richtig verrückt
irgendwie ja finde ich auch wer würde er
kalte Füße vor der Hochzeit bekommen 3 Z
ein
du
100% 100% zu 100%entig nein 100 h ich
doch nicht bin so gpannt bei sowas ja
aber ich habe auch schon die letzten
Jahre habe ich immer gesagt wir können
ja heiraten irgendwann wenn wir mal
heiraten
würdenen und du hast se Jahre gebraucht
um mich zu fragen ja ich muss ja sicher
sein dass du die richtige bist ja und
aber das unterstreich ja nicht dass ich
kalte Füße kriegen würde sondern ich bin
einfach super entspannt was das Ganze
Hochzeitsthema angeht ich würde da keine
kalte Füße kriegen bei dir K mir schon
eher vorstellen dass so ein crazy
mindflip hast oder was weiß ich ich zieh
jetzt nach Kolumbien und genau ich zieh
ins Ausland C in Kolumbien werde ich
hören ja aber du ne ich habe das aber
das Gefühl so oder sag mal so du bist
die emotionalere Person und ich bin eher
so rational ich glaube erst wenn wir
geheiratet haben dass du mich wirklich
heiraten willst seit du mich gefragt
hast bin ich immer
so ja weil ich auch schon so uh wir
werden auch in blogm noch zu einer
Hochzeitslocation fahren um sie zu
besichtigenin ich auch schon gespannt
und ich war so die erste die dann so
alle Hochzeitslocation ausgecheckt hat
und schon so überlegt hat wann heiraten
wir und so und du warst so ganz g lass
uns do erstmal verlobt sein das ist do
auch voll toll ja weil wir auch noch
eine Wohnung gekauft haben und das ist
auch noch mal fettes Thema ist was ja
auch noch so Kopf belegt so
gedankenmäßig kann man mit der Hochzeit
noch mal mit der Planung noch mal ein
paar Monate warten ja true okay das gebe
ich dir worauf haben wir uns geinigt
Vanessa ich krieg die kalten Füße ja
meine Füße sind warm wer würde er in der
Öffentlichkeit
furzen boah keine Ahnung 3 2
1 denke ich schon eher aber so richtig
lautfurzen wür ich e auch nicht machen
na ja aber man we W wä das eher so
unterdrückter man weiß ja immer nicht
wie der rauskommt wenn man ihn startet
ne es könnte halt sein dass man halt
aber sneaky das weiß auch nicht wie weil
in der Öffentlichkeit gefurzt hat
wahrscheinlich schon jeder also so oft
wie ich auf Konzerten bin und da
irgendwie dann plötzlich so ein pupsduft
aufsteigt aber auf Konzerten wer von
euch wer war das wer würde er heimlich
die Wände in einer Farbe die dem anderen
nicht gefällt anmalen 3 2 1 ich ja safe
du safe du du West einchen sagen das
vololl schön guck die Farben an perfekt
und du würdest auch dir denken so die
regt sich dann halt Z Stunden auf aber
dann schcht das ganze auch wieder ab
dann habe ich meine Wandfarbe muss kurz
vorer gehen um dann eben denkst landen
wirklich wer würde als erstes seinen
Kopf KL rasieren 3 2
ja aber du wolltest ja schon mal baskard
haben ne ja also kurz GZ ja und ich mach
ganz viel mit meinen Haaren du machst ja
also wenn das ist so lustig wenn wir uns
pärchenfotos angucken von den letzten
Jahren einfach mal zusammengesehen dann
sieht Timo
im gleich aus immer du kannst dein
Gesicht nehmen und das immer einfach
rüberpacken ich sehe jedes Mal anders
aus komplett andere Haarfarbe komplett
andere Frisur kurz lang blond verlängert
wieder short so man man sieht bei meinen
Frisuren ah das ist Zeit vergangen über
die letzten Jahre bei dir weil ich bin
zeitlos zeitloser
Typ ich hab aber schon versucht ich habe
schon versucht
einm die Haare länger wsen zu lassen
gescheiter kein Bo ich versucht war
Friseur gesagt die Haare länger ich möte
mir die Haare lang vielleicht 5 cm
länger als typisch der hatte dann an den
Seiten so ein bisschen dass er hinter
Ohr machen oh nee das nervt mich das
hier leicht gesagt das ist und einmal
hat ihm unser Friseur tommy hat ih
blonde Strähnchen reingemacht du hast
mir auch schon mal die Haare komplett
platiblond gefärbt ja am
Anfang wie nemen für eine Stunde für
eine Stunde und du ja auch blöd wer
würde er am Fuß des anderen
lecken obwohl doch du wer würde er aufs
Land
ziehen ja wer würde eher einem Kind das
Eis
klauen was denkst Du von
mir kindis kaufen wenn es keiner sieht
würdest du einfach so
wegnehmen Alter niemals so böse bin ich
nicht Leute wer würde er den Müll
rausbringen das ist der größte scam
wirklich beschw mich regelmäßig weil ich
immer den runterbringe wirklich 100% wer
würde eher an die Rezeption gehen um
sich wegen einem Fleck im Zimmer
beschweren ich will was haben für mein
Geld wer würde eher in die Dusche
pinkeln tut auch alle komm
verarschen wir t alle wir t alle wer
würde er einen Laden aufmachen 3 2 1 du
ammen ne du würdest Pizzeria aufmachen
irgendwas mit essen ja hätte ich voll
Bock ja du würdest was mit und ich würde
halt so ein Geschenkeladen
aufmachenes Ken wir das Verbinden P
geschen klein geschenkekartons ja
Fanartikel wer würde er den Geburtstag
der anderen Person vergessen
3 kann nicht akzeptieren aber wenn dann
wird mir
passieren aber auch nur weil ich einfach
bin
man
nein ich würde deinen Geburtstag niemals
vergessen du würdest s nicht vergessen
aber du würdest Dich sehr später
erinnern h auf nein wer würde er mit
vogm aufhören 3 2
1 ich ma ja nie vlogm kann ich nicht
aufhören ne nee aber jetzt also wenn es
jetzt so wäre du könntest jetzt z.B
sagen hey ich kann nicht mehr wir müssen
abbrechen ne wür ich nicht machen 100 jr
nichtchen komplett durchziehen du
würdest durchziehen ich hätte
wahrscheinlich schon den letzten Wochen
in den letzten 10 Tagen hätte ich schon
dreimal aufgehört wir schon paar Punkte
kurz vor breaking point war wo ichendwie
nachts noch da geschnitten du warst auch
voll abgefuckt weil du nur noch
irgendwie was den nächsten Tag überlegen
musstest noch mal vor Spiegel irgendwas
drehen musstest ich habe ja auch paar
werbekooperation im blogm obviously weil
blogm bringt halt auch wirklich nicht so
viel ein dass man jetzt z.B so eine
Reise bezahlen könnte deswegen freue ich
mich total über die ganzen Werbepartner
die wir finden konnen über die
Kooperationspartner
timo ist nämlich halt auch nicht also
der ist ja auch professioneller
Kameramann und Kutter und deswegen es
ist halt einfach nicht so so einfach und
deswegen ja freue ich mich aber es war
sehr anstrengend es war sehr anstrengend
aber auch sehr geil aber auch sehr geil
Bock immer oder macht Spaß es fühlt sich
aber wirklich an wie so eine Tour die
wir gerade machen ne
also noch so ein kleinen turourbus so
vlogmas
van durch die Gegend Cruisen nächstes
Jahr katter du bist Kameramann dann
holen wir noch ein Fahrer für unser Blog
krass wenn so jedes jahrmer größer wird
ir haben wir so richtigen Tourbus was so
Musiker haben riesengroßes Ding ja und
wir fahren damit quer durch Deut überall
auch live Übertragungen wer würde eher
nie wieder Alkohol trinken 3 2 1 echt
obwohl stimmt ich rede eigentlich jeden
zweiten Tag davon ob ich dass du gar
nicht mehr trinken willst ja trinkst
auch viel wenig also trinkst ja schon
wie viel weniger du machst dir viel
Gedanken darum ja ich habe in meiner
Familie viel zu kämpfen gehabt mit
alkoholik kann und so und deswegen bin
ich immer so dem Thema Alkohol auch
schwierig gegenüber was ironisch ist
weil ich ein erfolgreiches Format habe
was dre kom die ballern heißt genau aber
ich habe immer so eine so eine innere
Angst davor Alkoholiker zu werden wenn
man halt ein paar mal öfter was trinkt
und gerade in diesem Beruf ist es halt
voll schwierig mit diesen ganzen Events
da gehst du dann immer ja teilweise auf
drei Events in der Woche ja da muss man
irgendwann dann auch halt lernen halt
einfach nichts zu trinken und zu sagen
gut ich hau jetzt ab und ist ja auch so
in der Gesellschaft Alkohol ja so ein
riesen Ding es gibt so viel Leute die
glaube ich ein alkoholproem haben ohne
es zu wissen überall wo du hingehst
siehst du Leute trinken egal zu welcher
Tageszeit das ist so ein integraler
Bestandteil von der Gesellschaft
irgendwie absolut auch gerade in find
ich das immer so heftig wenn du da so
auf den Straßen bist so jeder sitzt da
in diesen Kaffes und so und hat halt
Alkohol in der Hand ne auch so mitten am
Tag um 12 Uhr eigentlich egal wo wir
sind überall überall wirklich ja wer
würde er Kinder wollen 3 2
1 wollt wir beide
sagen
natürlich wir beide will auch Kinder ich
will auch Kinder ja aber ich dachte
jetzt weil du du letzte Zeit oft davon
gesprochen hast ich habe richtig Bock
auf Kinder ich weiß auch nicht warum ich
auch immer wenn ich jetzt Kinder sehe
dann bin ich immer so s die süß früher
war das halt gar nicht so ich habe immer
gedacht auch schon so mit 25 27 keine
Ahnung auch mit 29 war es noch nicht so
krass ich hatte immer schon so gedacht
so ja später vielleicht werden wir auch
mal Kinder haben aber g gar keinen Bock
gerade irgendwie darauf und jetzt
mittlerweile auch wenn wir solche
Urlaube wie jetzt machen und Skifahren
und ich die Eltern mit ihren Kindern
sehe dann denke ich mir halt immer stell
dir mal vor jetzt mitd so einem Kind mit
uns sitzen ja ich du meinst ab ich bin
gespannt also wenn wir irgendwann mit
Kindern loslegen ob das halt überhaupt
so schnell klappt wie wir uns das
vorstellen ja ich habe jetzt ja von
Ariana barbori habe ich ja so ein
bisschen die Reise mitbekommen die
hatten wollten Kinder machen und das hat
den jetzt auch so zweieinhalb Jahre
gedauert boah krass okay das ist schon
ja ja schon heftig und ist halt auch
völlig normal dass manche voll lange
brauchen deine Mama hat dir auch erzählt
dass sie voll lange gebraucht hat bis
sie ja ja wenn man sich damit nicht
beschäftigt finde ich ich habe mich
jetzt nicht so viel richtig intensiv mit
dem Thema beschäftigt sondern nur wie
man es halt kennt vom Großwerden macht
man sich da keine Gedanken s man denkt
okay wenn man Kinderwunsch hat dann
kriegt man Kinder aber es ist halt ja
gibt ja viel mehr Komplikationen bei
solchen bei solchen Sachen viel mehr was
irgendwie klappt's nicht oder
voll na ja aber da bleiben wir mal
gespannt und jetzt gehen wir mal rein
und versuchen
es bis dann ihr kriegt noch ein Ausblick
zu sehen also macht's gut tschüss
tschüss gib ausblck
tschüs wow toll boah das ist mega schön
ist mega schön und und der Dings ist
gleich auf z000 runtergegangen ISO ja
Mensch klasse das ist ein schöner
Ausblick tschüss Leute
tschüss